Let us now look at some
numerical examples to get a
feel for how the central limit
theorem works in practice.
Let us look at a discrete random
variable that has a
uniform distribution in the
range here from 1 to 8.
If we add two independent random
variables, drawn from
this PMF, we obtain a random
variable whose PMF is the
convolution of this
PMF with itself.
We can even carry out this
calculation by hand, and we
get a triangular PMF.
So this is what we get for the
case where n is equal to 2.
Now we can keep doing this.
If we add four of these discrete
uniforms, of course
assumed independent, then we
obtain a PMF that starts to
have a shape close to that
of a normal shape.
And if you take as many as 32
of them, then the PMF of the
sum of 32 discrete uniforms is
almost identical to the shape
that you would get if you were
to draw a normal PDF.
So with n as small as 32, we
have essentially converged.
In fact, this convergence is
so good that in practice,
quite often people use this
idea to generate random
samples of a normal
random variable.
What do you do?
You draw 32 random samples
from a discrete
uniform, add them up.
And what you get is a sample
of essentially a
normal random variable.
Now in this example, things
worked out well for us because
the distribution that we
started from was nicely
symmetric and didn't have
any strange features.
Things are not always
so favorable.
Let us consider starting from
a truncated geometric.
If we add eight random variables
that are independent
and drawn from this
distribution, what we obtain
is a PMF of this form, which
does not really look like a
normal shape.
The reason is that there's
a pronounced asymmetry.
So let us add more and
more independent X's.
If we add 16 of them, we start
to get something that's a
little closer to normal.
But the asymmetry is
still visible.
And if we add 32 of them, we can
still see some asymmetry.
Namely, this tail here does
not look exactly like this
tail out there.
So in this instance, it's really
the asymmetry of the
original distribution
that makes it
difficult to converge.
And it will take larger values
of n before we can get a very
accurate approximation.